[Music]
this is a
discussion of the issue of the relation
between
philosophy and motion pictures
or as i prefer to call it moving images
since
um some some films uh some
examples of cinema of course are are
abstract but for sure i'll
lapse into just calling them movies
uh especially since the 1990s
uh especially here here in the states
and i think
perhaps the english-speaking world
more generally the period of the 90s
has been really
a period in which the the field has
expanded uh momentously
there are a number of publishers who
have series on
film and philosophy including open court
wiley rutledge bloomsbury and to a
certain extent the
cambridge university press and
of course there's a blossoming of
courses on
cinema and philosophy throughout the
the english speaking world
obviously one of the reasons for this is
uh
uh economic uh that is to say
that uh um both publishers
and deans of universities are aware of
the fact
that students are going to be attracted
to philosophy through film or philosophy
in conjunction
with film a bit a movie is the
sugar that helps the abstract theory to
go down so to speak
um so uh it is perhaps
somewhat predictable that as um
universities are more
tuition-driven um
at uh pressure or they're pressured to
um provide uh uh courses that that
students are willing to enlist in and um
publishers of course textbooks that
students who um willing to invest in
a a a book with the title hitchcock and
philosophy
is a little less awesome than
uh proloma gomez to a future metaphysics
again and i'm speaking particularly with
reference to the
united states and i hope uh
more generally to the english-speaking
world
baby boomers were especially responsible
for this uh rapid expansion in this
new new field in philosophy
i should mention it's it's not an
absolutely
new field as early as the teens before
the
20s uh philosophers like hugo
munsterberg and george lucas
had written uh uh about film
but the film didn't regularly enter the
curriculum until
probably the late 70s and early 80s
and and and then it took off as i said
in in
in the 90s um perhaps one reason for
this is gen
generational um baby boomers uh people
like me
who grew up watching old movies on
television
once we got our credentials um once we
could do damage in the classroom
um we wanted to use our beloved
objects uh as as um uh
two tools for disseminating uh
uh our philosophical views uh and this
uh baby boomers were of course um aided
by
previous uh of philosophers
it's not as though there was no
attention
by professional philosophers at least
to cinema in previous generations
a particularly important event
was the publication in 1971
of stanley kavel's book the world viewed
that that afforded the philosophy good
stamp of approval
on on the area of philosophy and cinema
because among other things cabell was a
member of
the very prestigious harvard philosophy
department
kevel gave us the opportunity so to
speak
and and baby boomers uh uh took it
as did succeeding generations um
and so here we all are in the midst
of a film that we could call philosophy
and cinema
one initial way to divide this
field philosophy and cinema up is
to divide it into a distinction between
the philosophy of movies on the one hand
versus philosophy in movies
on the other hand the philosophy of
movies
basically involves the
pursuit of the perennial categories of
philosophy
and the application of those categories
to to the movies for example
oncology or metaphysics the philosophy
of cinema
asks the question what is what is cinema
is cinema or an art these are
ontological questions about the nature
of cinema
there are epistemological questions
epistemology is the
study of knowledge so one
philosophy of cinema question
that's epistemological is for example
can documentary films
be objective another is
can philosophy can film do
philosophy that is can films
philosophize
that's a a topic we'll discuss
at somewhat greater length toward the
end of this presentation
then there are questions of
philosophical psychology
or are movie images illusions
um uh and what's the relation
of movies to the emotion that's a
question of course that you could even
trace back to uh plato's discussion of
poetry
in his his republic um ethics is another
major
area of philosophy and
philosophers of cinema composed
questions like
uh are are uh movies as such
good or bad or indifferent uh or
um if a movie say like uh rife instills
uh trying for the will has an
evil message can it nevertheless be
a good film in virtue say of its formal
qualities
and um the philosophy of art
also is relevant to
the philosophy of film um
[Music]
philosophers of film will ask
questions like are uh
as i just mentioned cinematically
accomplished films
uh uh that are evil good
uh but also other questions of the
philosophy of film
um that fall under the grand rubric of
philosophy of art is
um uh uh the the definition of various
film genres
for example uh uh what what is
con what is what is uh horror movie
what is suspense in movie
and of course the various
questions that genres raise
such as for example the paradox of
horror uh
how is it that we can take pleasure in
uh
viewing um things like dead bodies
uh in in movies in horror movies that
we'd never uh
want to encounter in in everyday life or
other paradoxes like uh one called
sympathy for the devil
uh how is it uh that we can sympathize
with characters
in films and and tv programs for example
um who we would steer clear of in
everyday life
uh how is it that we can sympathize with
um
someone like tony soprano
even though uh we would we'd hate to
meet him
uh uh in a in a business transaction
so to speak and so on uh philosophy of
cinemas
philosophy of the movies then is
the umbrella label for
the application of the standard
categories of philosophy
to to questions of of cinema and as i
said uh
philosophers uh have been uh interested
in in film as
as early as um uh the uh
teens of the 19th of the night of the
night of the 20th century
um very often at that time
they were interested in the issue of
whether or not some
film could could be art and if it could
be art
um could it could it be an art in its
own right
rather than merely theater in in a can
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas